diese filiale hat wirklich keine stern
verdient schlechteste bürger die ich je
gegessen habe rohes fleisch schlabbrige
kommen sie nach was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut heute
haben wir spontan noch das recht ein
richtig gutes nicht was trio ausgewählt
was leute eigentlich das mache ich
wirklich deutlich kleiner als ich okay
deutlich jetzt auch nicht aber was ist
das programm nicht nur die wollen
richtig ab nach geschafft als gemacht
damit kann man ja leute umbringen oder
ja auf jeden fall habe ich mir gedacht
oder wir hatten auf jeden fall geht es
jetzt ganz spontan zum schlechtesten
working hier in der city ich bin
wirklich gespannt im mcdonald's die
nicht matschig habt ihr wirklich war
schon ein wenig technisch aber die haben
da einfach da gab es irgendwie nicht
alles was ich wie schnell dann hatten
die mich so leute eigentlich habe ich
noch deutlich mehr bestellt das gabs
noch alles nicht wenn ihr das video noch
nicht gesehen habt dann schaut euch das
habt ihr mal an und ich würde sagen wir
fahren jetzt los und du kannst dann im
auto mal die rezension von ok ok ok ok
ok also so könnte wir sind auch schon
angekommen
da ist der laden also sieht aus wie ein
typischer bergen manche maria tage auch
schon gesagt hör sieht doch gar nicht so
schlecht aus
er war ja bei dem mcdonalds meiner
meinung nach auch nicht so viel haben
gesagt otto sidow ist also ein schuldig
bitte die lichtverhältnisse aber besser
gehts ja es ist auch schon dunkel wir
haben schon halb neun und jetzt ist aber
ganz wichtig wir schauen dass wir mal
kurz die bewertung an die würde ich dir
sehr gerne mal vorlesen und du kannst ja
dann mal gucken was du dazu sagt okay
auf meinem berger war keine brücke
sondern eine vergammelte salami scheibe
dieser werke ist echt eine schande für
die ganze kette ich habe noch nie so
unmotiviertes langsames personal erlebt
15 minuten wartezeit ist das schnell mal
gelaufen meist nur eine kasse auf und
dann wird schön ein kunde fertig
bedienen inklusive warten auf bürger und
dann erst der nächste kunde übrigens das
dingen hat ein fünf sterne bewertungen
halt nicht auf google sondern auf
ja ich bin mal also wer ist wirklich
gerade gar nichts los oder auch zwei
leute da ich die kette sowieso nicht
ausstehen kann wird mein bewertung
natürlich auch nicht rosa seien dreckig
ohne ende das personal schlecht für mich
und als dankeschön fürs ewige warten
kriegt man 40 servierten 10 weil mario
und fünf mal kritische texte haben
insgesamt 50 rap als dankeschön fürs
ewige warten kriegt man 40 servierten 10
bei mario und fünfmal cash opex trance
hütchen knallt quasi so ist oder stirbt
einer der schlechtesten king überhaupt
die ich kenne leider denn ich finde dass
beim fast food an jacqueline weiss nicht
warum der laden so schlecht geführt wird
diese filiale hat wirklich keinen stern
verdient schlechteste bürger die ich je
gegessen habe rohes fleisch schlabbrige
pommes die nach wochen alten fest
schmecken und das alles noch lauwarm
aufgewärmt und ich frage mich ehrlich
gesagt was man bei der zubereitung nach
genauen vorgaben noch falsch machen kann
das weiß ich ja nicht so lecker leute
also das steht wirklich nur schlecht ist
in den bewertungen und ich würde sagen
wir gern mal rein oder so leute dann mal
los weiß ich schon ich bin auch
irgendwie kaum noch bewegen
deswegen
alte leute da hat man doch direkt hunger
okay das ist schon hart aber ich meine
das habe ich auch schon mal schlimmer
erlebt also wir stellen jetzt mal was zu
essen
[Musik]
so also haben wir bestellt marie hatte
so einen schicken
ich hatte chili cheese nuggets eine
kleine cola parierte noch ein apfelsaft
und dann noch einen cheeseburger dazu
und pommes und hier habe ich jetzt
einfach mal die zeit gestoppt wie lange
es gedauert hat bis das essen da war
weil im internet war das ja so stark
kritisiert dass ich ewig dauert aber es
war nur etwas über eine minute
leute was ich ganz schnell noch sagen
wollte ich fliege morgen wohin und zwar
durch den günstigsten flug gebucht den
mann so finden kann
checkt es auf jeden fall bei mir ab
dienstag abnehmhilfen wir das kommt auch
ein video dazu ich wollte das jetzt hier
nochmal kurz anti sein also wenn ihr
bock habt das morgen mit zu erleben sag
ich mal über instagram 30 alles aber die
wartezeit bei ganz so viel lustiges
marie bestellt ein land schicken
der typ
damit bin ich da wurde sie die
kommission laut fig nuggets auf jeden
fall hat marie den lohntüten stellt der
typ sagt zum kollegen in der kirche
einen schicken
und er sagt einfach mehr fragt warum
also haben wir immer pommes sind zu
schwach zu stellen
es fühlt sich nicht öffnen
also mein burger sieht auch nicht ganz
normal aus wollte aber würde nicht mal
merken bin obwohl ich nehme mir das hier
chili cheese nagels dass das ganze wenn
er die noch nicht probiert hat die
schmecken sogar wollen uns die firma
[Musik]
schmecken wenn ich schon aufgebaut
worden und wieder
die konsistenz ist ganz anders sein so
leute das war's wir sind wieder im auto
und franz ist lecker nicht so gut also
ich muss sagen man hat bei fastfood ja
nicht hohe ansprüche ich habe auch
wirklich keine hohen ansprüche
allerdings weiß man ja wieso also
sozusagen burger oder so man weiter wie
das schmeckt oder ab und zu ist man das
ja zum beispiel wenn ich mit dem auto in
wahre auf autobahn was steht dann erhält
man mal zwischendurch bei burger king
ich fand den bürger fand ich nicht
schlecht aber als ich aufgehört mir
indem er so anzugucken waren irgendwie
so schwartze stellen und ihr habe ich
halt abgerissen so und das fand ich halt
irgendwie eklig und deshalb in der
ganzen kritik ja finde ich ist
verständlich ich habe jetzt nur gedacht
die pommes waren meiner meinung nach
scharf geschmeckt meiner meinung nach
haben
das kann daran liegen weil die chicken
lage jetzt in der gleichen schritt habe
keine ahnung also wirklich begeistert
bin ich jetzt nicht ich kann die
schlechten bewertungen aufgrund des
essens verstehen
aufgrund der schnelligkeit eigentlich
nicht nur das da hat schon alles hat
nicht lange gedauert jacken den haben
sie noch frisch gemacht wenn ich mal
nicht mit diesem wieso also die frage
aber hier eben schon erklärt marianne
schicken bestellt und hat der typ zum
anderen thema gesagt eine und tickender
und dann hat er einfach gefragt wieso
wahrscheinlich habe ich so was falsch
verstanden oder ich hab es auch so
wahrgenommen
na ja im großen und ganzen war das ein
flop es gibt auf jeden fall besser
parkings trotzdem ist es jetzt nicht so
dass man hier auf kleinsten hingehen
sollte also es ist okay wenn man keine
großen anforderungen wirklich so gar
nicht geschmeckt habe es ausprobiert
lassen dann nach oben da schickt man
lieber ins hat mich gerne auch und wir
sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich morgen
wieder frei